je suis un personnage public je suis
comme l'a dit Alain Jérôme une star
c'est souvent difficile d'être le fils
d'une star parce que on voudrait exister
par soi-même on voudrait
s'affirmer peut-être une dernière
question mais d'abord vous dire cette
cette phrase d'une retraitée bravo Alain
Delon pour son cœur sa sincérité et sa
franchise cet autre qui semble-t-il fait
de l'art dramatique restez comme vous
êtes vous êtes tellement simple et puis
ce dernier il y a eu beaucoup d'autres
question le concernant vous avez
commencé l'antenne ce débat de ce soir
en parlant d'un personnage qui vous
tient à cœur c'est votre fils et en
parlant notamment de la peur qu'il avait
du générique des Dossiers de l'écran et
beaucoup de téléspectateurs me disent
pourquoi est-il brouillé avec lui et
beaucoup souhaiteraient vous voir un
jour réconcilier ne serit-ce qu'à
travers le cinéma vous voir un jour
réuni sur les
écrans réuni sur les écrans c'est pas
une question de de souhait c'est une
question de sujet de scénario que nous
saons sur ment trouver un jour ou
l'autre réuni dans la vie vous nous
verrez c'est une question de temps c'est
une question de situation vous savez il
faut pas mettre les choses à une place
qui n'est pas la l'heure les rapports
entre alin Delon et son fils sont les
rapports de chaque père avec un enfant à
ceci près avec une toute petite pointe
de différence c'est que je suis un
personnage public je suis comme l'a dit
Alain Jérôme une star c'est souvent
difficile d'être le fils d'une star
parce que on voudrait exister par
soi-même on voudrait s'affirmer on
voudrait se réaliser on peut être quelqu
fois fatigué ou lassé d'entendre les
gens vous dire ah bah dis donc Anthony
c'est le fils de Delon ah bah oui parce
que c'est une chose qui peut excéder un
enfant et ça fait que des rapports
peuvent être tendus et peuvent être
difficiles mais pas plus qu'entre tous
les pères et tous les fils ou toutes les
mères et toutes les filles du monde je
vous l'affirme ça va bien ça ira bien ça
ira bien question de temps le seul
problème si vous voulez qui moi me me
blesse me gêne ou m'attriste c'est que
il a plus de temps que moi moi il m'en
reste beaucoup beaucoup moins que lui
justement vous venez de fêter votre
votre anniversaire au mois de novembre
oui le 8 8 novembre scorpion 2èe Décamp
bon et vous entrez dans dans un nouvel
âge si je puis dire pe-être dans dans la
décade qui mène vers les 60 ans par
exemple comment vous vivez ça mal
peut-être non non je le vis mieux
maintenant je l'ai vécu très mal à 50
ans pendant quelques années j'ai été ça
a été très dur très pénible j'ai j'ai eu
un passage où j'ai perdu confiance en
moi j'ai douté de moi-même douté des
autres douté tout le monde mais ça
suivait aussi une certaine époque assez
mouvementée et bouleversée de ma vie où
j'avais beaucoup souffert parce que ça
me fait penser à une phrase que j'avais
dans un film de ce merveilleux
scénariste audiar dans un film de Gabin
où disait la loi des hommes est la même
pour tout le monde et Gabin répondait
mais le désespoir non et donc on a le
droit c'est pas parce qu'on est talin de
long ou parce qu'on est x qu'on souffre
moins que les autres le désespoir est
tout à fait différent pour chacun et
donc j'avais passé et j'ai j'ai eu un
virage de de VE très très difficile j'ai
beaucoup souffert voilà c'est tout mais
on s'en remet et puis maintenant ça va
mieux parce que parce que la vie est
belle et vous sourez et je sourer George
baume oui George baume qui fut longtemps
votre agent votre ami aussi dis il est
le Parin de mon fils oui voilà disait al
il est l'agent de mon fils aussi alain a
tous les à tous les dons sauf celui du
bonheur est-ce qu'il a raison
aujourd'hui non il a eu raison jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il a eu raison peut-être
jusque demain mais il aura tort
après-demain et très souvent jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai souvent
eu l'envie ou l'idée de faire passer une
petite annonce en 10 an effectivement
j'ai tous les dons sauf celui du bonheur
etchangerai volontiers quelques dons
contre un peu de bonheur h mais je crois
que maintenant il aura tort dans très
peu de temps très très si vous aviez
pardonnez-moi de parler de cela mais
c'est vous qui l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure
euh si vous aviez à faire graver votre
épitap qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez qu'on
dit comme trace al c'est très simple
alors là je t'apprès dans Musset une
phrase qui m'a toujours beaucoup touché
beaucoup bouleversé parce que je pense
que c'est
peut-être l'épitaphe qui me ressemblera
le plus qui se se collera le plus à moi
c'est tout simple c'est ce ça c'est ceci
j'ai j'ai souver j'ai souffert souvent
je me suis trompé quelquefois mais j'ai
aimé c'est moi qui ai vécu et pas cet
être factice créé par mon orgueil et pas
un être factice créé par mon ennui voilà
j'ai souffert souvent je me suis trompé
quelque fois c'est moi qui ai vécu et
non pas un être factice créé par mon
orgueil et mon ennui voilà ce que
j'imeris
mett qu'est-ce que vous allez faire pour
Noël pour les fêtes
rien je vais le passer chez moi à la
campagne seul non pas
seul je ne suis jamais seul de toute
façon je ne suis jamais seul avec
moi-même parce que je m'entends
tellement bien avec moiême je suis
jamais seul je ne serai pas seul non non
je le passerai avec des êtres que j'aime
des êtres qui me sont chers des êtres
qui partagent ma vie et puis aussi avec
des chiens et puis simplement parce que
là aussi on rejoint un peu les larmes de
la petite enfance parce que je n'ai
jamais vraiment apprécié Noël parce que
je n'aime pas vraiment Noël parce que
j'en ai pas beaucoup eu et que Noël n'a
jamais été pour moi un grand
souvenir j'aime pas vraiment les fêtes
comme disait si bien it Pia je vais les
dimanches moi jeis les
fêtes je m' perçois qu'on a parlé de
beaucoup de choses mais qu'on a pas
parlé de de de long chanteur
ça a été une expérience un c'est une
telle
péripétie mineur dans ma vie minime je
me suis amusé j'ai décidé un jour de me
faire plaisir j'ai pas attendu l'année
dernière pour faire cette chanson au
cinéma j'avais m'étais amusé j'avit
comme au cinéma c'est ça comme au cinéma
j'avais j'avais donné déjà la réplique à
Dalida dans une de ces chansons j'avais
chanté avec Charles Basset j'avais fait
une chanson surtout pour parole de flic
qui s'appelait i don't know et puis la
semaine dernière l'année dernière ENF il
y a 2 ans on est V me proposer des
chansons que je trouvais assez
intéressante par parce que j'avais la
possibilité de m'exprimer de dire des
choses que j'ai travaillé que j'ai remis
moi-même dans ma bouche et que j'ai un
texte que j'ai refait que vous allez
peut-être entendre je crois et qui est
assez intéressant à attendre parce que
là aussi c'est le reflet un petit peu de
ce que je pense de ce que je suis de ce
que je serai
[Musique]
toujours